You are now live with Layer Eight Culture,
Tech Thursday.
All right, y'all, we're back.
What's up, what's up, what's up?
It's Thursday.
Tech Thursday, that is.
And, man, it's been a while.
It's been a minute.
We took a little hiatus.
There's a lot going on in the AI
space.
So we definitely have to catch up on
that.
It's been a lot.
Let's start with the basics.
I mean,
let's go back to layer A culture,
what we're doing, what the mission is.
All right, one sec.
There we go.
Yeah,
so let's talk about layering culture.
We'll talk about what it is,
what we're trying to do,
all that fun stuff tonight on Tech
Thursday.
So, GPT-Six is out, of course.
Well, I mean, there's a couple.
There's been a lot of models out since
last time we spoke.
But GPT-Six is the latest.
I think it came out, what, last week?
I don't know.
I can't keep track anymore, y'all.
But we got GPT-Six.
We've got Opus.
We've got Meta.
They came out with Muse.
OpenAI came out with DOTS, RockBot,
the new SpaceX SI models,
RockFourpointSeven.
We got ClaudeSonicFivepointFive.
There's a lot of models that came out,
but the principles, they remain the same.
All right,
so let's just get back to the basics,
y'all.
And let me see if this is working.
Cool.
All right.
So what layer culture is.
It's all about AI fluency,
building culture.
We make it, we test it,
we show it, we share what we're doing,
we build together.
Really creating what content that you need
instead of having to go out
and get something that's out of the box
or something that's already boxed up for
you.
Being able to create custom solutions for
your business, for your personal,
all with the power of AI and these
awesome tools.
And then it's kind of like, you know,
for us, by us, built by us,
built for us, that type of concept.
So, but the main pillar is AI fluency.
We want to make sure that we're able
to not only leverage this AI,
but also build with it, right?
We got to be able to use it.
Why is my,
I feel like my tag is like hovering
on my face here.
It's weird.
Let me fix this.
There we go.
All right, there we go.
I feel better now.
All right.
I feel like that thing was covering my
face up.
So, next, how to use it.
You guys know this stuff.
It's all about the model.
It's not necessarily about using ChatGPT,
but it's the models that you use.
So,
This became a really big thing,
especially once we got to start using
GitHub Copilot,
where you can have multiple models.
Even OpenClaw was one of the first to
really show this capability off,
where you can use multiple models,
you can use the free models,
you can use your OpenAI, your Cloud,
all that in the same harness with
OpenClaw.
Now you have GitHub Copilot
which allows you to pretty much access any
of the main primary models and be able
to build with them.
You could ask questions, you could build,
all that fun stuff.
Let's see here.
I'm just clicking through because I gotta
remember this stuff.
I'm like,
There we go.
The levels of AI.
Man, I love this.
So remember,
we all started at the consumer level.
That's using it as a chat bot.
Now you're using like eight out-of-the-box
agents like these Muse and Dots and things
like that.
But you're really just utilizing what's
already been given to you,
asking it general questions,
asking it to do tasks.
And then
get up to this builder operator phase
where you're not just getting answers but
you're getting solutions so and i'll i'll
show you an example of that because like
when we when we first started with uh
you know chachi bt even claude and all
gemini all the different ai models it was
always about like all right i'll ask ai
a question it's going to give me an
answer
And it's going to make sense, right?
Whether that's like a paragraph or like a
short answer.
But I think over the past maybe two
years, a year and a half.
I wouldn't say two years.
Probably a year and a half.
Probably a year, honestly.
We've gotten to the point where AI is
providing solutions instead.
So instead of saying, hey,
give me an answer,
to this question,
give me a video that answers this question
or give me a presentation that answers
this question or create an ebook that
answers this question.
All these different things are solutions
to your questions, right?
So that's the phase that we're getting
into.
And I think like as we go through
these different levels of AI,
like the market is also pushing
users to the next level like even here
like this level three is really where
everyone can be at just jump right into
any of these solutions from open ai or
cloud or anthropic like you can get to
actually build you know repeatable
solutions using these out of the box
capabilities
Now, when you get into operator, like,
I probably have to rebuild this thing
because, honestly,
even the operator level, some of that,
and I'm going to show you.
later on some of that is even available
in the capabilities like dots muse grokbot
because you have agents that are operating
they're not only taking any inputs from
you the user but also um generating like
like prompting you as a user like the
ai is now prompting you and saying hey
i got this uh
see this notification you know do you need
me to look into it you need me
to you know create a solution for it
like it's it's very proactive in that in
that sense in a way that it wasn't
wasn't before so we're getting to a lot
of that and of course about eight stages
all right cool let's get into fun stuff
let's get into
Let me open up.
Let me open something up here.
Let me stop sharing.
So tonight, let's get into GPT-Six.
You know what we do.
We look at the stats.
We break it down.
See where we're at as far as these
benchmark tests.
Anytime a new model comes out,
they're always providing insights as far
as what the capabilities are.
from the standpoint of the model.
So let's open up a new tab.
Hold on.
And they just dropped this intelligent UI
as well.
So we're going to explore this together.
All right, let me add this.
All right, here we go.
so intelligent ui like literally i saw
this an hour ago so i'm still digesting
it but when i say like solutions this
is what it's doing like it's um so
in this example here it's like hey break
down the design of a seven-speed bicycle
Instead of just like providing just words,
it's actually giving you the details.
Like here's the frame, the wheel,
like very visual.
I guess it appeals to people's learning
styles, like visual,
whether it's written or images.
Introducing intelligence.
So the text, visuals,
interactive elements, all is there.
Ooh, this is what I saw earlier.
So,
five point six instant provides you like
the text.
This is traditional,
traditionally what you would see with
ChatGPT, like the explanation, the tables,
you ask for a recipe,
like it'll give you, you know,
something that you'll see like in a blog
post, right?
But this, very interactive,
like you can see even this is more,
is it, yeah,
it seems more straight to the point.
like nice like it's sectioned off like
visually it pulls you into certain
elements instead of this it's like a wall
of text and that's one thing about ai
like
As we get this wall of text here
on the left,
you have to do a lot to disseminate
what's important and what's not.
You can't just take all this and be
like, oh yeah, I got a solution.
You have to really understand it,
take out the important pieces,
and apply it.
This seems to already have a lot of
information,
but it highlights certain elements.
This makes it easier.
Oh, and then, oh,
I see what they did.
So, when we talk about solutions,
like this right here is literally an app.
So, like,
instead of you having to ask it just
to say, how much should I buy?
How many people do you have?
Let's say you have ten people.
These are the measurements.
I wish it had, like,
a little thing that goes from the, uh,
You go to, what did we call it?
Pounds.
It's all kilograms.
Like that would,
that's something that you think would be
part of it.
But you copy shopping lists.
Okay.
It says also to pick up other things.
Yeah.
Checklist.
This is also interactive.
I mean,
It's not the best solution because you can
go back, like,
I shouldn't be able to go back and
uncheck things back here,
but that's just me being picky.
But think about these different elements
that were added, and you got the text,
you got the checklist, you have the table,
actually the app here.
It tells you what to get.
You have the visuals with the pictures and
images of what everything looks like.
And then you have kind of a dinner
plan, you know, heading header.
So,
and this is five and this is GPT
six instant.
So the important thing to know,
like remember when we were in chat GPT,
you have your slider, right?
so we can go let me bring this
up not that right it's gotta be an
easy way i need to do this properly
that's all right all right so remember
when we're chat gpt right here
click on the thinking effort you can go
here pro well i have pro but you'll
go here oh if iphone five is leaving
but under here you could pick five point
six soul and you have your different
levels of reasoning like the instant
basically get responses much faster it
doesn't it barely thinks and just spits
out the response very quickly so the and
then of course like pro extra high it
takes a little like that visual it's
pretty fun um it takes a little bit
longer to get your response but it's far
more detailed it does i do some validation
and checking before it gives you a
response which is cool i try to
I've been, like,
very conservative because I'm like,
I can't wait.
I'm not that patient.
I'm doing, like,
multiple different chats at a time.
So a lot of times I'll be up
medium.
Medium for building apps.
Actually, I'll do medium or auto.
And a lot of times when I'm in
chat, I'll just have it on instant.
And if I see like, hey, it's not,
if it's a like bigger question,
I'll turn it up to, yeah, correction.
I'll use GPT-Six on medium and turn it
up to pro when I'm actually building like
an app.
And I'm like,
and not really building an app,
but like doing a lot of planning.
on how I should implement an app.
I'll do pro.
For the most part, high, medium.
So let me back out of this again.
Let's get back to our...
Let me share this again.
Man, I know what I'm missing.
I'm missing the jams.
A little bit better.
All right, let's go.
So back to this.
So yeah,
I didn't notice that was actually GPT six
instant, which is interesting.
I was able to do all that,
which is good.
All right, next up,
let's see building wardrobe.
So again, very basic.
This is what we had in the past,
our point six instant.
It's now we've seen this before.
Do a couple of pictures in there.
Of course you have like a list.
It's not very interactive.
There's something you have to like copy
paste out or ask it to put in
a format where you can just print it
out, you know,
and then that GPT six instant.
The more organized we have.
Yeah.
Description under each image.
I was office for each day,
have an image already.
It's pretty cool.
And then here we go.
Another app.
So a packing checklist,
like progresses as you have everything.
Pretty cool.
Personalize your wardrobe.
Where are you going?
Where is it?
Italy.
Okay.
Then you can personalize it.
Then I click this.
It sends me to another prompt.
Hmm.
Okay.
So it's generating a prompt.
Wow.
Not even guys.
I fell off.
I wasn't even sharing.
All right.
So back to what I was,
where I was at.
Um,
this one is building wardrobe on the
left-hand side.
We got the five point six instant words,
a list, a check static checklist there.
And then on the right,
you have your more interactive GPT-Six
instant.
You have like text under the images.
Your day by day already has kind of
pictures next to it to visually see.
Interactive checklist progresses as you
pack.
your things.
Then down here it has a personalize your
wardrobe kind of creator.
I think about this is that it allows
you to select different things.
And then when you personalize my wardrobe,
all it does is it sends you to
ChatGPT with a prompt that's already
embedded.
Interesting.
I mean, it's instant,
so it doesn't have to be an overly
complicated solution, but you see, like,
instead of just providing an answer,
we're providing a solution.
Like, here's a checklist.
Here's a checklist app that you can
actually go through and then, you know,
click things as you check things off as
you pack them.
You got to plan a road trip.
Again, oh, yeah, add maps.
So like,
there's so many different pre built
interactive elements that open AI has
added.
Pretty cool.
So tend to itinerary is awesome.
Day by day.
And we'll see.
Yeah, this is a prompt.
Plan an epic ten-day road trip through the
Pacific Northwest.
Nice.
Budgets.
When are you planning the trip?
personalize your trip.
So very similar to the last one.
I'm sure once I click this,
it's just going to just basically
pre-fills a prompt for me, which is cool.
Nice.
All right.
So learn complex topics more easily.
Hmm.
Interesting and open AI is really they're
tapping into some interesting markets
here.
Is this in its in itself will be
amazing for education.
This almost takes over like Khan Academy.
And it's pretty cool.
Yeah, it's definitely,
this is definitely proving how we changed
the way we learn.
Because at this point,
it's not just putting information out in
front of you,
but it's also like testing you.
Like, I think this one had, you know,
how do you explain GDP?
It had some questions in there.
We actually had to answer the questions.
And of course you have the voice
capabilities like, yes, really cool.
Like very,
some of this interactive elements again.
And yeah,
it's going to change the way people will
learn.
People learn for sure.
All right.
Create interactive experiences just by
asking.
Go splitter.
I saw this one.
So like, you just take,
you take a picture of your receipt.
And then boom, it creates an app.
It's all interactive.
And then look,
it's just from the picture of the receipt.
And look, it's all right here.
So like, because I have.
Okay.
I had it here.
Five.
That's why I split into five.
Okay.
All right.
So like who had this string person,
one person, one person, one, two,
same thing.
I see your head on there.
Okay.
Okay, so it's like a bottle of wine.
Everyone shared it.
Appetizer, everyone can share.
Think about your tip.
Split the check.
Wow.
That is cool.
So, man, just like, ah.
Trying to think, like,
Again,
like even with like Siri and like those,
when we had intelligent voice assistants,
like this just goes way beyond that.
The fact that I could just go and
just pick up my phone and take a
picture and then boom, I have an app.
I can use that, get,
get all the answers.
Like we're creating solutions.
Man, it's awesome.
All right.
And then of course we love our charts.
I mind you, this is GPT six instant.
Yeah.
So answers far more faster.
And these ones,
so if it needs a web search,
what percent sooner, that's really good.
Nice.
remember five point five is out so it's
literally gpt five point six and gpt six
didn't we didn't they drop gt gpt six
point one they did oh i can't keep
up i don't even remember what happened six
point one to be honest like honestly i've
been using claude and we're probably gonna
um
We'll do,
we'll do a clawed episode next week
because clawed five point five is a whole
nother beast.
But I must say like it's, man,
it's neck and neck guys.
Of course I got my open AI pro.
So I have been loving that,
especially with the new stuff that's
dropping from open AI with the GPT six.
Oh, here's six point one.
One second.
Saw it.
Here we go.
Six point one.
So near Astra intelligence.
Well, I, you know,
a lot of it is still around us,
right?
See, it's like, here's the main headline.
Like Astra is still top of the line,
a powerful model.
Sol is still a powerful model,
but the cost is much less.
So your inputs are ten dollars,
outputs fifty dollars,
things like per million tokens,
to ten dollars.
And they're saying five point six is very
close to six Astra.
And we got the charts to prove it.
All right, here we go.
So, I mean, as you can see,
like it is actually outperforming some
aspects.
Okay.
So the caveat is that this is operating
at
So if I point six, six point one,
so is operating a higher effort to meet.
Hold on.
Okay.
He's all right.
Got it.
Is the same efforts are across here,
but it is performing better.
than gpt six so but then we still
have luna so okay yeah gpt six luna
they gotta clean this up they gotta this
is confusing so it's six six point one
six and i know i did this six
point one souls because they want to
compete with
sonnet now they want to compete with five
point five opus all competition so I'm
pretty sure they'll probably clean this up
this versioning is confusing like even
when I went to come back to my
chat I don't have
I just have six, five point six,
so five point five.
Now, let's see.
OK,
so if I go to work at it,
so I'll show you guys real quick move.
So there's so much going on, though.
Right here.
so under work if you click the effort
button then click on this then you have
all the different models right five point
five is still gonna be gone fourteen but
you've got five point six luna terra soul
you know about those and you have six
luna
So Astra, this is confusing.
I think you have GPT, six point one.
So, oh my gosh, like yeah.
I haven't even touched six honestly on the
work.
So on work mode, I actually don't use,
I guess I'm using GPT six and work.
I haven't used all for a while.
So that goes to an interesting point.
So like, let's go back to,
before I jump into the dots and muse
and all that fun stuff,
let's go back to our research.
So.
GPT six point one.
Six Astra.
incredible and the cool thing about astro
like the main thing is this computer use
and i've been man i've been really digging
into this oh it costs a lot first
of all it's very expensive you saw the
numbers already um what was that like five
times the cost of soul but when it
comes to computer use here's the here's
the cool part
First of all,
you have to have a computer, right?
Whether it's a virtual machine or your
computer that you're using already.
And you're logged into the ChatGPT app.
And let's say you're building something.
Instead of you going through and say,
I'm using AppCut.
I could tell the AI to use AppCut
to build something.
That's computer use.
Like it's actually using an app.
on your behalf based on the prompts that
you're putting in.
So it goes beyond like using a browser.
It could use anything on your computer.
And like you could have done that before,
but it's very accurate.
So I was doing some, some cool stuff.
A lot of people were building like games,
video games and stuff.
I installed Unity, which is a game engine.
I installed Unreal,
which is a game engine.
I was building out like some,
like a three D game.
that actually connected to my spin bike it
worked like of course it was like not
very wasn't refined but it worked it cost
a lot of tokens but actually did work
and um just interesting to understand that
i do need to go back
on a couple of older projects and really
lean into these newer models like Opus
five point five and even GPT six.
That's the thing when it comes to building
with AI.
Sometimes it's best if you don't already
have like a solution that's say you're
sharing or that's live,
you're sharing on the internet or
something, or as an app,
if you're just using it by yourself,
you just start from scratch and say,
here's the, you know,
you can still have the same files.
I've done this before.
Like here are the files that I have
currently,
but I want you to literally build a
new solution,
solve this problem and see what it comes
up with.
You might be surprised.
Yes, Blender, that's what it was.
And so here's Unreal Engine,
I just explained to it.
This is actually something that, you know,
Astra created.
Just insane.
Blender is a tool that you can install
on your computer,
do a lot of three-D modeling with it.
This is all created by AI.
So you can create a three-D model.
You add like the layers and textures on
top of it.
That's how you get like these three-D
images or worlds actually.
This is something you could probably
rotate, move around, do a virtual tour,
all these things because it's a actual
model to create it.
So it's beyond just a picture or even
a video.
It's literally like a three-D world that
you can create with AI,
which is really cool.
All right.
Cool.
So let me see if it,
did they have anything on?
So we know that, um,
Facebook came out with Muse and it was
like a week and a half ago.
And like,
I used it and I was like, oh,
this is pretty cool.
Not too bad.
And then OpenAI dropped bots and I was
like, oh, I'm using bots.
Or no, not bots, DOT.
And I don't know,
I just like DOT because one,
I'm already part of this OpenAI ecosystem.
but like Muse has its own VM.
So it has,
it has its own computer already, you know,
but I don't know.
Maybe I'm just used to,
you know what it is.
I really like how open AI and chat
GPT, I can have the web.
I can have the web actual website.
I can go to the app on my
computer.
I can go to my phone and have
access to the same chats,
same capabilities across the board.
There is one caveat.
I need to test it out because before
like my work stuff, like the co-work,
what do you call it?
Codex.
Codex stuff or the work stuff would only
run on my desktop PC, my laptop.
But then when Dots came out,
I think it is more seamless across the
board.
Anyway, man, I download,
I got access to Dots and I literally
uninstalled Muse.
I was like, disconnect everything.
I don't want you to have access to
anything.
But, um,
that is really cool because of course,
just like news, I was able to like,
already,
you've already had already have my plugins
connected to open AI.
So it's the same setup.
I just activate your plugins.
If you have multiple Gmail accounts,
you could do that.
You know, your Google drive, your GitHub,
everything you connected to, um,
And I don't know.
I feel like it's more smart.
I think I feel like news is more
of a, Hey, I'm a personal assistant.
Like, Oh, I'm just here.
I'm your buddy here to help you.
But dots is more like,
I'm here to work.
Like I'm here to, yeah.
Bring your dots work.
Like a dot is here to work on
your behalf and actually get some work
done and like help you achieve goals and
like really drive things forward.
Um,
really cool and then the thing is like
it's constantly like you just you don't
have to worry about separate chats like
you could just literally give it back to
back chats with different subjects and
it'll parse it out and they'll just get
back to you when it has an answer
if you need to like hey I need
this answer like quick right now it'll
give you a faster answer or prioritize
like the work that you wanted to get
done
One thing I do wish when playing with
it is that I wish it had a
way to quickly get to the dot from
the app.
You have to open up the ChatGPT app,
then go to your dot,
and then ask questions.
If it was just an actual dot app
where it's like,
I just want to talk to my dot,
that would be perfect.
I didn't know it was integrated in
Microsoft Teams.
Nice.
Integrated with Slack.
Of course, you can customize it,
of course.
I like how it follows the screen around.
Pretty cool.
So let me show you my dot.
All right, cool.
So I have like a special name for
a dot,
but I finally today I was like, oh,
let me customize my dot.
And the cool thing is like when you
move your mouse,
it's actually following your mouse around.
So it's pretty, pretty cool.
It animates itself.
And like, yeah.
The dot is pretty neat.
So definitely try it out.
I like it.
And this literally just came out.
And then it works twenty-four seven.
So let me... Here it is.
There you go.
Now you can see my dot.
I forgot to add it.
Another thing I forgot to mention,
you could actually,
of course you could update it,
give it a face and all that.
You can call it.
So literally you hit the call button,
opens up a phone call,
and you can just talk to your dot.
And then you hang up, you know,
finish the call.
Um, I did try, I was like, Hey,
can you write the call me?
It doesn't work that way.
I'll be cool.
Pretty sure you could set some
customizations,
set something like that up.
I want a little gecko dot.
And then like when I'm moving my smile.
You can see the head like follows.
And if I'm asked a question,
I'll start thinking, you know,
if you're working and stuff,
it's pretty cool.
And of course you can edit here.
Before I had this cloud image,
I actually liked the cloud person a little
bit better.
They have all these different characters.
here, you create a custom character.
Looks really cool.
I'll keep messing around with it later.
Let me stop sharing again.
So yeah, that's what's happening in AI.
And then even the actual app,
let me show you what it looks like
there.
Because it is a little bit different.
Let me get that for you.
Thank you so much.
Here we go.
So this is the actual ChatGPT app on
my computer.
And like when I go into my dot,
where is it?
Where was it?
So the dot has its own browser,
which is cool so that when you're asking
it to do stuff,
it can open up its own browser.
It's not going to affect your browser,
your Chrome or your edge or whatever you
have going on.
And then it also has its own virtual
machine,
which for some reason I can't remember how
to add it.
There it is.
I was tripping.
All right.
So under profile,
it's like the dot has access to my
computer,
but then it has its own computer.
And if I click here,
I actually see my dots computer.
Like it's a, what is this?
Like a Mac.
It's like a Mac OS.
But, um,
No, it's more Unix or Linux.
It looks like Linux-based.
It has its own apps.
You could definitely have your permissions
added onto it.
If you have your own account for your
automations and stuff,
you could just use that account.
Of course,
you could drop whatever files you want in
here.
It's already got files based on the
conversations I've already had.
Everything's like stored here,
which is really cool.
And then that way it has easy access
to it.
Even if my laptop is off.
Literally has its own computer.
So,
and then I could interact with it too,
like, which would be neat.
And on top of that, like I said,
it has its own web browser.
Pretty cool stuff.
And then from here,
I can still call it.
Let's see what else.
I never tried the reboot.
Activities, yeah.
That is very cool.
you know one thing I would say like
I think definitely the next and Facebook
did or meta did um kind of hint
at this like the next step would be
the um and I always on device like
it had like a keychain thing
that they want to release in the future
for Meta.
That basically,
it's your physical form of your muse.
Let's see if we can pull up an
article real quick.
Let's see.
trying to find this article.
the muse charm you know that's the thing
about being the first
Sometimes it's just gimmicky.
I mean, it's cool and all, but.
No.
Sexual.
Here we go.
It's like, it's pretty cool.
It's cute, you know,
but I would say like,
if you had this device,
but the dots instead,
I think it will go.
That's the thing about open AI.
They haven't really come out with the
product yet.
I feel like when they do come out,
well, when I say product, I mean,
they're a physical product.
Like I feel like when open AI comes
out with a physical product,
It's game over for a lot of this
competition.
Reminds me like a Tamagotchi back in the
day.
Little pet.
We'll see.
I don't think this is gonna,
I don't think this is gonna go though.
You know what?
It's good for tonight's stream.
I mean, definitely using the dots.
Actually, no,
I'm gonna leave that for next week.
GitHub Copilot, the app.
I've been using that a lot more.
I still use my CLI.
I'm definitely not using visual code
anymore at all.
I don't, yeah,
I don't use visual code anymore.
everything is in github copilot which has
some really cool capabilities um does it
allow my own vm it doesn't allow my
own vm but it does have its own
browser which is cool again upside with
that browser use and yeah so next week
we'll talk about github copilot
We'll get into Opus five point five for
sure.
Cause I'm using that with everything app
related.
I can create my apps.
I'm using Opus five point five.
It's far more, far better than Astro.
All right.
So it's good to be back y'all.
Lariat Culture.
The grind does not stop.
And actually there's new Lariat Culture
lo-fi.
jazz i want y'all to check out so
definitely check out larry cultural radio
we got new videos one just dropped and
then we'll have another one coming up this
week all right so remember keep building
y'all peace